let's jump into this first story
um wow welcome to the age of Internet
drama and gossip as uh nothing is really
happening in the news you can all go to
bed uh I guess or you can hear us talk
about someone's Private Business which
shouldn't be on the front page of the
Daily Mail and shouldn't be trending on
Twitter but here we are uh Stephen
Crowder has addressed the video that was
released released broken marriages are
ugly in them people do ugly things
Stephen Crowder they say doubles down as
he claims wife leaked edited video of
his verbal abuse
didn't like isn't that true though
didn't Candace Owens say that the white
his wife is the one who released the
video footage uh for those who don't
know video footage was put out by yasher
Ali I think we have it here and uh it's
actually not that bad I just don't want
to play it because it's just ridiculous
that yeah sure I gotta say yeah I know
yeah sure like to a certain degree like
on Twitter and we've dm'd and stuff I
don't know him personally
and uh I've I've messaged him stuff like
I don't know just dm'd and stuff he sent
me something recently
this is some of the most disgusting
stuff I've ever seen if someone came to
me and said I have video of jenk yuger
fighting with Anna kasparian I just be
like I'm not interested have a nice day
leave don't kick don't care are they
together no I'm saying like if there was
some personal beef between some
commentator and somebody when uh when
there was the fight between genk yuger
and the Union at his own company oh
that's totally different like there was
they were trying to form a union and
Jack apparently was yelling at him and
here's the account of the people because
that strikes at exactly what their
politics are different story yeah if
they were like they were having a
personal fight over like a parking space
or you know something he was eating and
I I don't I don't I don't want to talk
about this but here we here we are and I
find myself
hearing I mean for one Candace Owens
airing the story criticizing Crowder and
I'm just like why
for for what what what reason did this
story become
front page trending it could just be
retaliation for the whole situation with
the daily wire when he came forward of
the contract dispute which literally
makes it worse it just makes it even I
don't think the daily wire as a
corporation has anything to do with this
no no I think uh well I'm just like it
could be I don't I shouldn't speculips I
literally have no clue what I'm just
that's one thing that comes to mind well
I'm saying Candace Owens doesn't like
him because of this so I think Candace
has chosen to uh cover this story and
she does not like Stephen Crowder right
I knew that about them it's I don't know
it's one of those things where obviously
it does not look good for him but if you
know I was saying before the show like
if you're a judge in a divorce case if
you only saw one party's Discovery or
there are claims you're 100 of the time
gonna think the other person is the most
evil disgusting person on Earth
um we have known I don't know nothing
but his wife I know nothing about the
background no it is I don't know sort of
uncomfortable the comments and I'm just
this is we know two minutes of the
relationship and it looks bad for him
but it's literally all I know so let's
let's play Crowders statement which has
four million views on on Twitter there's
a text statement with four million views
and then the video with a million here's
what he said I commented on my ongoing
divorce on Tuesday requesting privacy in
the best interest of the family but also
by court order agreed upon by all
parties look broken marriages are ugly
and in them people do ugly things myself
of course included I would never claim
otherwise however
due to recent misleadingly edited leaks
to the Tabloid press without context and
not subject to consequences of the Court
well if not privacy the next best option
is truth so today I have filed a motion
to officially unseal all files as they
relate to the matter of legal record
finances relevant medical records
including mental health history or
evaluations depositions and any motions
or sanctions from the courts of Texas I
will not be leaking private marital
information to the Press but if the
Privacy Agreements are not respected by
all parties I will address all that is a
matter of irrefutable legal record in
full context next week I think yeah sure
lied uh I watched the video yesterday I
didn't realize there was a three minute
video I thought yeah I should only put
out 20 seconds so that was my mistake
and then I did watch the video and I
think yasher Ali lied about the context
and is trying to manipulate the framing
to make Steven Crowder look as bad as
possible well there is this one quote at
the end where he says something like
they put up the quote on this forget if
I'm going to f you up I think but they
say it's off camera and we just the most
damn in claim we sort of have to take
their word for it and by the way y'all
sure I know this is the side of the
point but he went into hiding for like a
year because there were some Daily Beast
article about him where it came out he
was like couch surfing and like Kathy
Griffin's couch and wouldn't leave like
just bizarre stuff with this guy so he's
not uh the most credible guy now like it
you know changes the clip or anything
but uh just I don't know another guy I
think could be getting that much
attention in the first place the whole
thing is just gross it sucks that that
this is the topic du jour it sucks that
there is the just the video got out at
all this is the LIE right here so maybe
I'm wrong but let me tell you what I
think in yahshua's article it says
Crowder gets irritated and says that if
Hillary his very pregnant wife takes the
car he can't go to the gym see his
parents or see his friends
you know what it actually sounds like
and this is why I'm telling people watch
out for these videos like the Covington
Catholic kids
he doesn't say in the video if you take
the car I can't go to the gym I can't
see my parents I can't see my friends he
says something to the effect of I can't
see my friends I can't see my fam uh I
can't see I can't see my my parents I
can't go to the gym I can see my friends
every moment of my life is is
um like tracked under the second but you
can go do whatever you want how does
that make sense but it sounds like
they're having an argument about
something we've not heard because the
video is pulled out of context and I
really first of all you gotta understand
this too not saying Crowders innocent
I'm saying ask yourself why it is they
are arguing right now on this patio what
started it you don't see when you see
stuff like this for all we know a Native
American guy walking deceiving crowd and
started banging a drum in his face
screaming at him and then she stood
there with her arms crossed the Native
American guy leaves and then she says I
love you Stephen and he goes what stop
and then it makes him look bad not
literally you get my point though the
things that I think really make him I
don't know look bad as a word but the
whole one car thing could obviously look
very controlling
um you know telling his wife to get an
Uber instead of driving so it's just
little things like that I think people
might pick up on even if the clips is
out of context and then also things too
like if I had an eight-month pregnant
wife I don't think I'd be asking her to
do a house chores at that stage I'd
probably pay someone to do it if I had
his money
um so you know enough to give a marriage
advice or anything what money does he
have
allegedly he gets paid for his show no I
don't know what his net worth is I would
assume though it's probably in the low
Millions if not that's another mistake
people are making it's like the
assumption that Crowder's Rich when in
fact he only has one car and this was in
2021. I you know what I remember there
were some numbers on how many paid
subscribers he had but I I'm drawing he
didn't know because he was contracted
with the ballets see this is the thing I
don't like about people see this stuff
they make assumptions Crowder's got
millions of subscribers therefore he's a
millionaire he might be but I don't I
don't know that for sure even if you're
pulling like 400k a year you can pay
someone like 10 grand a year to do chore
I don't know I just feel like it
shouldn't be a problem you can't pay
someone 10 grand a year maybe I could I
don't I don't I mean like if you did a
part-time I'm making up numbers
obviously but I just mean you could
afford uh something probably if you're
gonna have someone work full-time doing
like housekeeping stuff you might be
able to pay um low hourly wages but I
think it's important to point out I
don't know
uh
how much Crowder made and this is from
however you got to understand he was
under contract with the blaze so my
assumption is and again I don't know my
assumption is he probably signed a deal
a long time ago and was not getting his
paid as much as people think he was and
he's got staff and production costs when
he was going to do the deal with the
daily wire that probably would have put
him personally into the millionaire
category but that may have been his
first foray into it yeah we don't know
for sure they think of it 10 grand for a
butler it's probably cheap I'll tell you
what I think I think uh the video was
clearly bad I think Crowder recognizes
there's there's there's bad things in it
I don't trust Yasha arle's Ali's framing
he says as they headed inside Crowder
got anger and angrier and was by his
admission via audio I reviewed yelling
angrily I will F you up everyone just
believes it reminds me of members I
don't trust these people they were 10
years ago when there was a Clipper Mel
Gibson was having this apocalyptic
end-of-life explosion at his girlfriend
that got leaked and on her side her
reaction was very common controlled kind
of like stop talking to me that way
that's not nice and you could tell it
was a setup
you know in this situation I could see
someone making that argument but then
there's also the case that Steven knows
she's on he's on camera too so but but
look man I've done phone calls with
people and you know they're being
recorded but you don't expect someone to
knife you in the back it is weird like
even on shows like this you do kind of
forget anyone's watching if you know
after a certain amount of time I don't
think Crowder ever expected that his
home security camera would would be
weaponized against him in this way
that's why I deleted my ring the first
thing I first saw that that's crazy I
would not have these things like we have
we have security cameras but in your
backyard sir closed circuits turn
them on when you're not around turn them
off when you're outside doing your thing
unless you want everything you're doing
recorded to be weaponized against you
because
there was this uh period where people
had all these cameras and you could
easily log in anyone could log in at any
point anywhere and 4chan excuse me
published a link now if you click this
it will show you everyone's cameras damn
because it was just not secure yeah so
here's how I kind of feel about this
seems like they were arguing about
something else
it seems like we're only getting the
snippet where it's very convenient that
his wife is saying stuff like I love you
you're so abusive and then Crowder is
being like what you you won't you won't
give the dogs medicine granted his
wife's pregnant you really shouldn't be
he should probably go lay down yeah but
it feels like there's something else
here that we're not being told about
Crowder doesn't want to talk about it
and his hands are tied they've put
Crowder in a very very bad position
where they can lie about him in any way
they want and no matter what he says
people will attack him for it and they
might be sitting on another thing
similar too so if anyone defends it then
it goes oh well what about this you know
people people are saying too like uh
or I guess yeah yeah I'll just that that
was the point all right there there's
more there's probably more there waiting
to release people are saying like well
Crowder's the one who brought this up
Crowder clearly mentioned this because
he knew the video had been released to
people like yasher Ali and the fact that
is white I'm just gonna say it right now
as as soon as I found out that his wife
is the one who leaked it or I should say
if assuming it's true then I am
immediately not on her side Yasha Ali is
is not a trustworthy individual he is
one of these leftist corporate
journalists and he's clearly framing
things to hurt Stephen Crowder and
you're not getting the full picture so
for a short here's the other thing too
about the I will F you up
should he have said it no if he did
would you assuming he did should have
said absolutely not but hold on in your
mind how did you hear Stephen Crowder
say it
or you're saying if you do this I will F
you up I'm telling you okay I shouldn't
have said that but I'm I'm saying I'm
saying I will go to court was it
something like that yeah and then Yasha
saying yelling angrily and then Yasha is
going to be like well I think that was
yelling angrily I mean that's just my
opinion I mean to me it's an opinion
piece to be fair as you're yelling that
in the back of your head you're going
This Woman's taking half of everything
I've ever worked for so you know it's it
just seems like the issue is they're
clearly arguing about something we don't
know about and in this snippet she's
very much like I love you so much
Crowder and then Crowder even says you
keep saying this but you're so what I
what I think is probably Crowder is
probably and this is just wild
speculation right now seems like he's
frustrated that he works all the time
doing this show getting all this Flack
getting demonetized he's working and he
doesn't feel like she's a partner in
this that's why he's saying stuff like
you you're not doing wifely things the
media yasher they're trying to frame it
like how dare he be so sexist to say
wifely things when it may be the context
that he's like all you do is go go go
talk like hang out with your friends
you're not you're not carrying the same
amount of weight that I'm carrying and
I'm asking for a partnership I'm not
saying he's innocent I am not saying I
know the context I'm saying consider
these things because they're not giving
you the context and I'm not going to
make assumptions I'm gonna I'm gonna
explore the possibilities and then say
prove it to me or else yeah I'm I'm just
listen it's someone else's business mine
is just it looks bad but I've been
giving two minutes of context into a
10-year marriage but I know enough right
there yeah yeah and then my question is
like why did Candace Owens Put this out
but also if your wife is eight months
pregnant just maybe you should do some
chores instead I think yeah you're right
about the the fact that I I understand
stand that sentiment but like does
Crowder work 12-hour days that history
probably works obsessive hours is he
coming home smelling like crap drenched
in sweat with oil all over his face
because he just did a show and planning
and then he and then he comes home and
he's just like all I'm saying is give
the dog their medicine like this is the
challenge I see for all we know Crowder
Works an hour a day and as a staff do
everything and he shows up and he just
he's a funny guy it's easy for him and
then he sits at home smoking cigars all
day doing no work and his wife was like
then I'm not gonna do anything either
I'm not so I'm saying you know maybe
he's not a good dude but I mean you know
how many how much effort these kind of
shows take just to put on the research
so you know obviously the guy works
obsessive hours I mean I see that even
with Dan I don't know how he does it
physically so yeah it's quite a bit a
lot of work that's why I'm like I wanna
I don't trust I don't trust anybody in
this and uh
I don't I don't think that like right
away just Candace should not have
published this that's like a big major
huge negative in my opinion I that I
find that to be kind of like low brow
just just what the do we have a
confirmed that she is like I know that
the link was from Steven's wife to Yasha
I didn't know did he also send it to her
well I just I'll I'll put it this way I
don't think Candace should have come on
our show played the video and then
started you know they probably have some
huge behind the scenes things and um and
and I I will I will absolutely take
Flack for us even having talked about it
but like when Chris comes out he gets a
million hits because he's addressing it
directly and I'm like but at least well
we're talking about it we're emphasizing
how much we don't want to be talking
about it so so now we're now we're
innocent now anyway next time I I said
it in the beginning I'll say it again
I'm like I would rather be talking about
a lot of other things but I do a part of
me is concerned that Crowder is is
extremely important in pushing Back
Against The Establishment pushing back
against War
uh corruption deep State Etc and he's
been put in a position by this where
he's he has no ability to provide the
context to defend himself because of
legal reasons and because of PR reasons
and I personally understand something
about the pr lock where people can go to
the press and make up stories about you
and you are legally barred from
defending yourself I I so I see this and
I'm just like this pisses me off
you know like I I would love it if we
knew exactly what a full detail but he
even said for legal reasons he can't he
can't break down everything that's
happening it's it's likely that you
won't actually get full like the full
story too because they'll have some kind
of like uh you know let me tell you guys
disclosure comps uh claws or whatever
Crowders got this this big company he's
got this big deal and he's going to lose
half his assets
so I'll tell you this we'll speak in
pure hypotheticals you got somebody who
runs a company that's worth a lot of
money but also has a lot of employees
and it requires those resources to pay
those employees you get sued by someone
who's worth nothing who gets a law firm
on contingency who who knows that you
will be forced to settle they then start
leaking fake news to the press that the
Press eats up and spits out and then if
you say anything the courts will
admonish you and so all you can do is
say they're getting away with it because
they have nothing to lose they have no
money they have nothing there's there's
no employees there's no risk if the
court comes at us because we counter
their lies in the corporate press so
they launder the smears through
intermediaries and then you are left
sitting there unable to do anything and
even if there is a follow-up they know
that for every let's say 100 people that
see the original video how many of those
original 100 are going to see the
follow-up workers no actually this is
what happened nobody ever maybe you see
that on Twitter where it'll be total lie
50 000 reviews tweet then the LOL JK
gets like three shares and you go they
may know they do it on purpose too
nobody ever sees the retraction either
when it comes up in an article thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time